before we get started I want to give a
quick thank you to Kurt spell for
sponsoring this video
Kurt spell is a third-person action
battle game created by the same people
who made el sword and grand chase two
other games that I play and really enjoy
Kurt spell really stands out to me as an
anime fan because it is so clearly
inspired by anime and playing this game
makes me feel like I'm actually
participating in an anime instead of
just watching one I love the epic battle
moves and special attacks which make
this game extremely fun to play and the
customizable characters with extremely
cool designs really enhance the gaming
experience I was fully immersed into the
story and the great character
interactions right away
some of the characters are very very
developed and as soon as I started
playing I was able to get into the game
and have fun right away one of the big
features of this game is the PvP mode so
you have the option of using your
favorite combos against other players
too the game isn't officially out yet I
got to play it early but I strongly
encourage you to click the link in the
description and add Kurt's belt to your
Steam wish list
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I want to talk about
Mele Otis's
own original power or original magic
that's been shrouded in so much mystery
make sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
cemetary sense content leave suggestions
for future videos you would like to see
in the comments and falls on instagram
at enemy opera for quality seven deadly
sins memes we also have polls for what
future videos you want to see so be sure
to check us out on instagram at anime
uproar if you haven't guessed by now
there will be spoilers in this video
you've been warned in Chapter 283 while
bon Mele Otis's emotions and wild are
fighting and losing to the demon king
Mele Otis tries to use full counter but
it has no effect on his father the demon
king points out that full counter the
move we often associate with Mele Otis
is just an imitation of Chandler's
original magic it isn't his own he just
learned it from his teacher then he says
and I quote unless you use your own
original magic you cannot fight me but
even that's not possible because you're
afraid so we learn here that Mele Otis
not only has an original power aside
from full counter like soldier stand
demon king do we also learned that it is
strong enough to give him a chance
against the demon king who is pretty
much presented as an all-powerful God in
the world of the seven deadly sins talk
about hype then after the fight bond
brings this piece of information up he
tells Mele Otis that he did admit that
full counter is a move he was taught by
the demon Gramps referring to Chandler
so he asks does that mean you have some
other original magic all your own Mele
Otis looks like he's blatantly lying
when he says now that's a good question
I gotta say I'm beyond clueless right
now it's clear that he doesn't want to
talk about it
suggesting that the demon king is right
Mele Otis is afraid to use it later Mele
Otis questions his father about
something we've all been wondering why
is he so obsessed with Mele Otis even
though he always calls him a disgrace
and good-for-nothing
why is Mele oldest special why doesn't
he get preoccupied with zelgius his
younger son for example why must be Mele
Otis then the demon king answers in the
official translation because you're a
source of destruction then he says
because you're the source of destruction
this slide has been alternatively
translated as because you are destroyer
you're d destroyer so the reason that
the demon king is preoccupied with Mele
Otis is because he is the source of
destruction aka the destroyer I believe
that this line has to do with the great
power of Mele Otis's original magic
which must have great potential for
destruction when bond and Mele Otis's
emotions are escaping purgatory the
demon king reaches his hand out and
grabs Mele Otis Mele Otis tells bond you
don't need to worry about me anymore
I'll make it back on my own strength now
I swear it then we see the unimaginable
happen the demon king whose outer layer
of skin could not even be scratched by
wild losses his whole right arm Mele
Otis's own strength seems to have
clearly been a reference to his original
magic the demon king is shocked he says
to his son a power capable of destroying
my flesh Mele Otis it can't be
then Mele oldest responds to his father
you said so yourself I'm afraid and you
were right but now that I've awoken to
my power even when I'm back to the other
side I won't be able to stay there but
it's still what I've decided to do that
Mele Otis lasts because it is the first
time his father looks panicked
his father screams no not that even need
to mention it but I will this whole
scene is extremely significant we get a
lot of information about Mele Otis's
original power number one he's finally
willing to use it number two it cannot
only harm the demon king it can take off
his entire arm as I mentioned before
wild couldn't even pierce the top layer
of the demon king skin and here
malleolus is able to easily go through
the demon King's Armour skin and bone
and take off the entire giant arm number
three the power is strong enough to make
the demon king completely lose his cool
and even shout out no this is a huge
deal in and of itself since the demon
king viewed to be as powerful as a god
never lost his composure so bad before
number four
Mele Otis suggests that his original
power is so strong that he won't even be
able to stay in the human world anymore
even Eska normal with such
and the new-and-improved bond don't have
to worry about staying in the human
world and they're extremely strong the
smelly Otis's original power must put
him on a whole nother level altogether
we could assume that malleolus is
original power is strong just by looking
at how Opie his family's original powers
are in the case of his father the demon
king his original magic is called the
ruler and it allows the demon king to
change attacks and weakening maneuvers
made against him into healing and
rejuvenating ones in other words it
causes a reversal even when someone like
bond can somehow turn the power against
him by trying to give him power which
ends up hurting him he can simply
deactivate the spell so in most cases
the demon Kings original magic makes him
near invincible while bond just so
happened to have a power that is the key
to overcoming it because of such an
ability he could in theory take on the
strongest magical attacks you can think
of like miles o P greatest son attack
and have it heal and rejuvenate him
instead this can even apply to the
strongest attacks that the supreme deity
may have to offer so it really is an
Opie ability especially since it can
simply be deactivated if someone learns
how to use it against them so just as
true original power ominous nebula is
also amazing as Merlin explains it
generates a force field with a powerful
suction power around zelgius it only
works on living things and physical
attacks can't reach while enemies are
assaulted by an attack when they get too
close this attack comes from zelgius
increasing his concentration to the
limit he revolves his own darkness at
top speed creating an intense whirlpool
that pulls in all nearby creatures to
him anything that enters the range is
cut down by a slashing attack so Swift
it's impossible to avoid by any spinal
reflex combine this attack with the
ability he's borrowed from the demon
king which makes magic attacks useless
against him and ominous nebula too is a
near invincible unstoppable attack as
Merlin points out it's an attack that is
impossible to defend against and on top
of that physical and magic attacks don't
work on him he can even drastically
increase the suction power so that
Merlin cannot even teleport away in time
Ludo shahu thanks to his grace flash is
the fastest swiftest characters in the
series admits that zelgius power works
so quickly that even he can't keep up
with it he suggests that the power is
entering a divine realm that surpasses
him Ludo shells power level is above
200,000 and he still can't do anything
about this attack even with his speed
which demonstrates how opie it truly is
however unfortunately for zelgius s
kannur uses the one form the incarnation
of invincible power to stop the attack
nevertheless he is only able to stop it
in this form that lasts for one minute
of the day if it was any other time of
day the team members present would have
been defenseless such opie original
powers definitely foreshadow how
powerful Mele Otis's original magic is
gonna be when we see it directly
remember that zelgius is weaker than
Mele otis and the demon king
specifically seek smelly Otis's youthful
and strong body suggesting that he has
even more potential than the demon king
he needs meliodas because he's the
source of destruction the destroyer his
original power lightly has the potential
to achieve a level of destruction that
zelgius and even the demon king himself
are incapable of in chapter 270 when
bond and Mele Otis's emotions are
talking in purgatory bond points out
that now he realizes just how insanely
straight up not smelly Otis's power
truly is he points out that the flames
and ice of purgatory couldn't leave a
scratch on his immortal body even the
demon king couldn't after sixty years of
fighting but Mele Otis left a scar on
him that never healed
this leads bond who has had a huge
transformation himself to think that
when Mele Otis is back in his body he'll
be truly invincible this is probably a
nod towards Mele Otis's true opie
original magic that can seemingly break
the rules and even inflict lasting
damage on an immortal body when nothing
else could this great original magic was
also hinted at as early as chapter 29 of
the manga a kingdom named Donna fall
said to be just as powerful as Leonys
was completely wiped out in the past by
melioidosis power when he lost himself
to his wrath this act makes what the
demon king and the supreme deity did to
the capital city of wizards belly
allowin seem like child's
play they rain curses and mists of death
Hellfire and lightning over the city for
1000 days destroying it
Mellie Otis on the other hand seems to
have completely wiped out an entire
kingdom in a moment of Wrath
this must be malleolus is original power
this power to cause mass destruction on
a level that no one else not even the
demon king could match this power can
destroy immortal flesh and even the
demon Kings body it can destroy an
entire powerful Kingdom in the blink of
an eye this power must be why the demon
king is obsessed with Mellie Otis this
power must be why he calls him the
destroyer or the source of destruction
it makes sense that Mellie Otis would be
scared of this power because it can
cause unimaginable amounts of
destruction and death in the human world
the power is so great that Mellie Otis
probably fears that he could not control
it fully once it is awakened so he feels
he must leave the human world before he
does any irreversible damage this is why
with his original power Mellie Otis has
a potential to even surpass the demon
king who knew that without the power
Mellie Otis didn't stand a chance
against him but when he saw him use it
he completely lost his composure for the
first time knowing that that power could
lead to his own defeat to a gods defeat
and that is it for today's video if you
liked it make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and bring that
notification valve so you don't miss any
new 7 Deadly Sins videos follow us on
instagram where you can find daily seven
deadly sins memes and even vote on
future videos as always a huge thank you
goes out to our supporters over on
patreon especially to our pro hero tier
patrons keelon and the one and only
gilgamesh if you like what we do and it
gives you value you can also support our
content by pledging as little as $1 a
month and your name will even be
featured in future videos among these
amazing people right here thank you
again to Kurt's bail for sponsoring this
video remember to click the link in the
description and add this awesome game to
your steam wish list thank you for all
your support and until next time see us
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]